foreign
Debra's in Philadelphia hi Deborah
welcome to the Ramsey Show
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
I would like to help my son get into a
single family home and I'm not sure the
best way to go about it
because he needs your help
qualify for much of a mortgage he's
currently renting a house with a
roommate
my son recently got engaged and he and
his fiance would like to live together
unfortunately I'm over in New Jersey and
Lance here are just crazy they'll never
get ahead if they got a rent and Deborah
you're not going to like me
or me
you don't need to do you don't need to
do this
no why because you're not helping him
you're enabling him
he hasn't got his crap together enough
to go buy a house you're going to get
him into a house and it's going to be a
curse not a blessing because he hasn't
got his crap together to get into a
house
well in which way do you say it's going
to be he's broke you said he can't pay
the bill the reason they won't give him
a loans because they know he isn't going
to pay the bill and then you get him
into the house and he doesn't pay the
bill why because he can't pay the bill
well I kind of look at it as
giving him part of this and hurricanes
now he's going to give him a house for
free
I don't know about that but then you're
gonna sign him up for something he can't
do
that's not a blessing Deborah well how
about if I were to buy the house and he
rented it for me how about your grown
son becomes a man
okay that's what you should do he needs
to be on his own he needs to stand up
he's going to get married to this girl
they need to sit up and have a life
instead of mommy taking care of him
really this is not good for him Deborah
it's not good for him I know you're the
sweetest lady on the planet and I'm
being mean to you but you're just trying
to be helpful to your little boy but I
got to tell you one of the things I had
to do with my wife when we were Raising
a Son was to let him be a man let him
Sharon no yes you can't do you've got to
young people have to have dignity yes
and she owes it not only to him but this
is the side I see to the girl that he's
dating because she needs to see what
kind of man this is going to be and if
mommy is swooping in and paying all the
bills so they can live together and
she's never gonna see
who he truly is he's disqualified as a
proper husband at that point hey guys
mom and moms and dads you know love your
children enough to let them do hard
things called life like I told you
Deborah I told you at the front of this
you weren't gonna like me and you're not
gonna do it you're gonna go in there and
interfere and screw this up because you
ain't gonna listen to a thing I said but
the the deal is that moms and dads if
you will let your kids find their way
coach them
cheer for them if they're in a really
hard pinch be a safety net but don't
interfere we're seeing data right now
that 25 percent of Millennials their
parents are paying for their housing in
one way or another
let me just tell you moms and dads not
good not good for your little millennial
they are much better off to face some
calluses some stress some hard times
make some hard choices stand up and
square their shoulders and be a man be a
woman instead of a child it's not good
for them they're not good for themselves
they're not good for their spouses
they're not good for their employers
because Mommy and Daddy swoop in and
take care of everything bad plan America
bad plan so Deborah we love you you're
sweet you love your little boy but he's
not a little boy anymore